oh my god who is this is he trying to be
Indian I'm gonna go with Indian for
those first one am i right
oh god it's Ashton Kutcher I remember
this no no what the [ __ ] looks like you
just like rub dirt on his face and put a
mustache on and a really bad wicking
it's sad because Ashton Kutcher was
totally my celeb crush when I was in
elementary school never dress up as an
Indian again I'm guessing he's supposed
to be Chinese because he's wearing silk
robes he has a really long mustache so
I'm guessing Chinese even if you want to
do like a loving tribute to like the
genre of conclude you like do you really
need to put on this like fake mustache
he looks more like the rat that betrayed
Harry's parents and Harry Potter they
definitely didn't try this is a white
guy
I don't know who she's supposed to be
because she looked like a white woman
yeah there's Emma Stone playing some
white girl in a hat I think they just
gave her some mole freckles they're like
yeah that's exotic no I would never
guess that she's supposed to be part
Asian I would assume she's in like some
Desperate Housewives show she looks all
white to me like they didn't even try
hey don't tell me she's supposed to be
black she's not supposed to be black
with this girl here Hispanic baby is
she's supposed to be a biracial black
woman why would they make her Afro Cuban
there are too many Afro Cubans in the
world he looks like Rachel Dolezal
the fact that like someone like her goes
out of their way I think to like aid in
humanitarian causes in other countries
it's like gal play an afro-cuban woman
like no that's stuff you can't trying to
be a black woman sorry I've been
training all my life and I still
struggle with the role you can't just
like put on some makeup and some
stereotypical clothes and suddenly
embody that culture and are like a true
and realistic way you just can't because
name recognition and like box-office
success are not valid reasons I mean
movie starring people of color like fast
7 they do very well please stop doing
this